hey this is 20th Century Fox we had a
nice thing going on things are better
the world is better we made x-men movies
and everyone was happy but then Deadpool
happened and we learn something
something important you people are sick
he freaks you want the hard are we added
in all the VFX blood you psychopathic
skin handles these x-men are full in
front o plus they've got my potty mouths
I need oh he's my father what I'm a my
mom I know dish is a nest in WB keys
Plus this guy is in fast oh yeah and
these two people might like never felt
like this before from the studio that
brought you Deadpool it's Xmen
apocalypse we're riding a wave
all the way to the back